خلافات اربيل وبغداد على فقرتين في مشروع
الموازنه الاتحاديه تمص الصلاحيات
الدستوريه للاقليم الكردي تهدد وبحسب
مراقبينا بانفراط عقد تحالف اداره الدوله
الذي بموجبه شكلت حكومه محمد الشياع
السوداني فالاتفاق السياسي ما بين بغداد
واربيل لم يترجم على ارض الواقع بحسب
اربيل بل ان هناك ما وضع العصا في العجله
لايقاف الاتفاق كما توقعنا انهم ينقلبون
على شركائهم دائما
غالبيه والاطار التنسيقي للاسف لا عهد ولا
ميثاق لهم وهذه ليست المره الاولى وكانت
متوقعه ولكن الديمقراط الكردستاني وباقي
الاحزاب يعني تعامل معهم بحسن نيه نجح
الديمقراطيه والكردستاني في تاجيل التصويت
على مشروع قانون الموازنه الاتحاديه الى
اجل غير مسمى ويسعى الى مناقشه مستفيضه مع
شركائه في تحالف اداره الدوله لا قناعهم
بان التعديلات الاخيره للموازنه بمثابه
رصاصه الرحمه للاتفاق
اما في بغداد فالمشهد ينذر بمزيد من
الخلافات بين نواب الاطار التنسيقي من جهه
ونظرائهم من الكرد خاصه بعد تهديد نواب من
الاطار بسحب الثقه من النائب الثاني لرئيس
البرلمان المنتمي للحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستاني
هذه الخلافات داخل البرلمان سببت حرجا
كبيره لحكومه السوداني والتي تنتظر اقرار
الموازنه بفارغ الصبر لتنفيذ برنامجها
نامل من خلال الجهود السياسيه التي تحصل
الان
يعني مع مختلف القوى السياسيه على ان نمضي
باتجاه عمليه الاقرار هذا الاسبوع او قد
يكون مطلع الاسبوع المقبل ما يجري هنا في
بغداد يشيب بوجود نوايا لدى اطراف في
الاطار التنسيقي بالتنصل من الاتفاقات
السياسيه التي مهدت لتشكيل حكومه السودان
هنالك قوه اساسا هي تدرك تماما لتلتزم
بهذا التحالف ثالث تريد ان تحرج الحكومه
حينما ذهبت بمنح الاكراد رواتبهم لعده
اشهر هذه مساله اضافه الى كل هذا هذه
القوه اساسا قسم منها لا تؤمن وان كانت
بائتلاف اداره الدوله لا تؤمن بمفهوم
الدوله بل تؤمن بمفهوم الفوضى
رغم عمق الخلافات تبذل قيادات وتحالف
اداره الدوله جهودا كبيره للخروج من هذه
الازمه قد تسفر عن انفراجات قريبه سامر
الكبيسي العربيه بغداد لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات